hello and welcome to another episode of
riffing with Griffin they make sure I
look too fat this is a listen I every
episode I say a special and this one is
really special to me right now and and
before I get to the you know as you guys
know I do a different theme song I have
another great theme song that I'm
looking for I think this might be the
one but before I do that let me
introduce two of my favorite people in
the whole wide bless your heart
who are they know ladies and gentleman
let me welcome to the show Mary Beth
Monroe and Jillian Bell and I was so
glad you did and I want to play
something for you guys this is another
way I have to make sure that I I
mentioned something here because this is
made this is another theme so I made by
the great Lamont Landers this really
goofy white kid but he's like a soul
he's like a soul singer and it's really
great but I also want to mention that
his wife Amber Landers shoutout
yes she's she just went to basic
training in Fort Leonard Wood yeah so
she's in basic training she's out here
fighting for the country and he's there
making music you know so that's an
amazing have our strengths yeah we don't
have and this is his strength right here
and this is a special one just for you
guys oh yes
[Music]
welcome to that when I get up in the
morning with Gillian yes
I'll wake you up like never about Monroe
when jelly on mouth that's the great
Lamont Landers I want to thank him for
making another great banger
but anyway ladies I just I haven't seen
you guys it's so long I think the last
time we were together in the same it
wasn't even one of the workaholics um
after parties cuz I don't know if we all
made it to all of them in the last
couple of seasons the last one no I
didn't go to work because I was out of
town that was the one to go to you know
here we go exactly we season before yeah
no I don't think I was there we all
there the second one was pretty amazing
on the rooftop that one yeah but on the
Henry Ford yeah Henry Ford no when we
made the cups remember we made the cups
we were it was so specialist I know I
wish I had that picture so enthusiastic
I know we still were that was a great it
was a great experience I would I
wouldn't trade it in for anything you
know I love to every moment of that and
I just remember the season one like you
knew the boys beforehand right I did
yeah I did the like original pilot
presentation with that wait were you in
that oh I wasn't and they had two weird
Alice in that one out weird Alice I
don't know who that woman is but I
thought of her a lot that was the first
Alice and they were like yes so you knew
them and you I knew them we all
auditioned to be in like National
Lampoon was doing a tour a sketch comedy
tour and we all auditioned for it and
then they gone in as a group and I got
in as like a solo performer Wow
that's how good Gillian Bell is that it
wasn't you went with them
no woman show it was like five minutes
to do characters or something and that's
how I come on come on is spot-on doing
that I was guessing and then my
enthusiasm got the better of me I'm
sorry your love you're lovely and here's
the thing I'm so honored to be on your
show this evening I'm just so happy
about it I love when she gets emotional
in movies that's my favorite yeah i'm
not josie grossy anymore
usually do that you you had developed
that one later that was later I don't
even know what I did for this one but I
just found a sketch that Adam and I
in the show cuz we so we put together
the entire show we wrote stuff it was
like SNL but for one show we're all
submitting sketches and and musical
little performances they did stuff as
the Wizards oh and oh my god I love the
Wizards and Adam and I had this sketch
where he I was dying I was in a hospital
bed and he was my husband and the whole
thing he's like I love you so much I
love you too and I was like I promise
you that I will always haunt your dreams
what please don't do that
I'm like I'll be there at the edge of
your bed every evening play find someone
yeah and then it went from that then
they just at the same time they were
work they were developing and then
comedy central right they were so they
did a bunch of shows and they did like
any sketch shows they were like will you
come be a lady in it I was like she laid
E we need a lady
there's Jilly and they're like will you
be a cool aunt I'm like sure and then
cue your aunt coming in and then yeah
and then they they were writing the show
and they're like do you want to play a
weird lady if we write you into the show
I was like you know Kyle was all right
he was telling me how like that's like
not even the idea that they wanted to I
get made lately it was like the least
like the least important one they had
all this high concept nonsense do they
want to know they're the sketch they did
with mail order comedy online right that
was and they literally did that sketch
because they were able to get an office
like that's late they found out they
could have an office space and so they
wrote this like a sketch that was like
the Prem that was the original you know
kind of premise for workaholics just
because they got to work in circles like
you know and then they made it and then
here we are well I love to know what the
other idea I know well they want to do
the wizard wizard yeah yeah yeah space
throws about nipples just Blake and
that's right but this worked out pretty
yeah I know so I remember if like for me
I always talk about my first audition
but I didn't even know about you the
youth they had you audition like
numerous times right didn't your time I
went in like five times twice for the
casting director and then actually four
times yeah twice for the casting
director and twice for network / like
one was for them and then some of Comedy
Central okay and then I had a big test
against the chick who played Marcia in
the Brady Bunch movies Alanna urbe
uh-huh she was me and her it was down to
me and her to people out of business
this yeah and it was like it was super
fun and I improvised I just remember
having like a little directors session
with Kyle beforehand and he's like we're
gonna do the scenes but we really want
you to improvise him you want to show
them basically we want you to just
improvise how you improvised in the
audition just for us the first audition
with Network you know yeah and I
literally went in there and I was Pony
DUP exactly what I did in the previous
so I improvised I did all these jokes
but like I was with Adam and we were
both doing but some like this is what
they want to do like reom provides jokes
that I did so yeah anyway but they work
but they totally worked but it was it
felt a little like I'm improvising I'm
not really improvising yeah right now
cuz I've tried this because I've done it
but yeah same thing for me is written I
had four times it was like four times I
had no idea
Wow but it was weird because it was like
I got all these weird notes and then
like you got another no than another
know that you finally got it and I
remember that my first table read
like so many of these because remember
the first one the first few table reads
it was like the room was packed yeah it
was like everybody was in there and then
like everybody was taking credit for me
getting this part I just remember that
like
yeah all these people coming up I took a
lot of credit
team I don't know what you're talking
about
no I'm talking about no I'm talking
about people like these you know how
they had like you look at that book
there's like a million executive
producers I'm talking people were coming
up to me in a room like Eric when I saw
your audition I knew it was you know it
was like that kind of thing it was like
they put the word in where was the love
on one you know it was but I always
remember like season one that was the
fun time I think that was a funnest time
we had because I just remember we had
our little our dressing rooms but like
near each other off in that weird corner
we had to be so quiet there were so many
scenes like yeah shooting gorillas show
never really done with whatever we all
had dressing rooms that had windows too
outside and there would just be a man
yeah I feel like we frosted half of them
yeah so he can't see why it was you're
up six episodes into season one where I
was like oh they're watching me changed
yeah just straight-up watching me 100%
and because you're right it was kind of
half frosted like they tried and they
tried to put blinds up but there was
still just clear vantage it was like
someone went you're the Teamsters Easter
break they go on but it was still that I
just I enjoyed the first season I always
I always say the office campout that was
my favorite episode because it minimizes
what the shows about
you know just them being them you know
that the Three Stooges of I have to say
checkpoint gnarly was my
gnarlie we did my brother Brad oh that
was just just because that was I just
loved what they did with that character
away yeah and just made him so endearing
yeah and so cool and I just loved I
loved that episode wasn't there an
episode where you kissed Margaret grass
were you kissed did you get I work my
grass later that was like last season
Wow you've been like a limo I don't even
know the place somebody's jealous he's
still thinking about that didn't you uh
make out with north crapper what did you
do cool Alice it was like when Alice was
cool with like braid braces I had braces
and like yeah I pulled up in a limo and
it was it was the I cannot think I have
such mommy brain but um mind doing this
flashback I could not fill a flashback
with a flashback I had the big hair
garbage you guys something is happening
to Grandma
over here cuz you're my brain gone I'm
like you guys like gnarly checkpoint
gnarly and I was like this yeah I love
it
oh no that's because someone you've been
working soon no I seriously will go to a
movie with someone and then two days
later be like have you seen this movie
it's excellent or like I went without
you alarum a knee I love you I feel very
bad for that person I just go to movies
well I know Jillian is do you have
enemies you don't even remember a
favorite no I do I I don't know what
episode this was it'll be like selfishly
I like the one where I take over because
I was in that a lot I got to play with
everybody
gamma 1 gamma 1 names great but there
was one where the boys it was on them
and and our characters were just
supposed to be in the front of the
meeting like she's saying something and
then it cuts to them talking so it's
just the two of us talking about ground
for any background and and I remember
Kyle was the director of this and he
kept being like you guys you're on
camera like stop laughing cuz she would
just look at me and go
Julianne like that and I would laugh
every time and she'd be like Jillian
you smell like actual garbage and I'd be
like I was in a garbage can last night
that's what and then she would laugh
like we were just it was so much and
they're like you guys don't even have to
say anything just act like we're talking
more like we I know you'd think we had
we would have had a ton on the show but
we really did cuz I was your assistant
and [ __ ] you I would yell at you and
leave well that's what I did with
everybody on that show basically but
nobody did it better though but like you
being my assistant we would have more
eyes I thought you were gonna say well
we when I had to get you off that oh the
velcro
oh the velcro white paper I've never
laughed so hands down so we related it
or it deflated naturally right it was
posted in place yes
and then we were like I'm stuck here her
crying she's like we rolled harder than
anyone predicted velcro one thing yeah
they had well so far shoes are flying
everything I know I'm like coming to on
top of Jillian my ass just in the camera
it was if you look back on it like all
the weird things that they did like
other other shows and things that you've
we've all done I look back on that like
I I don't know sometimes I look back
like why I even agree to do like spooky
I mean I even remember like the first
season where I'm looking at the thing
and it says you know Montez comes out
the bathroom naked you know I had a
scene they changed it it did it was
still pretty graphic but I was supposed
to be on was Liam Hemsworth or who was
on our show Liam Hemsworth yeah yeah I
was supposed to be on his shoulders with
my skirt over his head we want giving me
cunnilingus at one point I'm gonna have
to put the definition of that I'll be
home later Liam that's my baby's name
Liam this is impossible what you're
asking like right can't the skirts I
wear theirs their pencils hurts right
yeah yeah I'm his shoulders like what
I'm gonna be in the front of him like
all right I was like this can't happen
so then it was in like the last season
right I was I feel like in the last
there's a lot of like yeah well you just
fought this guy and you're like what I
have to have sex with someone on camera
but like will you just do it one of my
favorite things though in the last thing
I want a like masturbated in a car girls
together in the first season I think of
a second yeah right yeah I don't know
now I forgot you know me how was your
how was your dog oh my dogs gypsy in
vallejo my ring on Alejo
Alejo has he did attack another dog and
a hair so he can't go to daycare anymore
well they didn't say he could and he had
a warning oh good
I'm not gonna send him to daycare
anymore yeah yeah you got it did you get
the call my god Nicole I was like this
I'm in Disneyland I don't know happiest
place on earth are you calling I am
seriously an adult baby who's who I'm
adult baby with a baby because you I
keep saying that leg I just wanted some
congratulations
don't know I'm excited I'm very let's
see I wanna see
I want you to respond genuinely okay
because I get you I get the gamut when I
tell people her name here we go huh it's
Monroe Monroe is her first name Monroe
Monroe last name is Cobb Monroe Adrian
Cobb so interested so she told me that I
know what did I tell and I cried why I
was like that is so cool to me there's
always like Jesse Jr and instead like
taking a woman's last name that she's
not gonna use my name yeah God it really
this was my husband's idea yes you know
he's like hard or like feminist loony
lefty guy and he was like I just think
it's a really great like [ __ ] you to the
patriarchy for her to have your last
name and I was like I'm the one that was
like but is it like will she have her
own identity is it it you know I don't
want her to like people no it's not like
people no no no you're like your last
name you know I'm saying like with
people that are gonna know you know your
and your fan
they're not gonna call you Monroe yeah
and I think she's gonna own it she's
gonna make it her own you know to me
they'll be why are you trying so much
you know what's so interesting is
Jillian did cry most women I tell are
like really moved and most guys are like
rising divisive you know what I want to
say what I agree I hate men I'm single
this is a good segue into something you
know one thing I'll always appreciate
about you guys is that you know you are
on the forefront of like always talking
about like certain issues especially
when it came towards for women and it
was it always always left conversations
with you guys being more thoughtful by
thinking like oh you know I didn't
realize that this kind of stuff was
going on and like the things you guys
were talking about was pre meet the me
to movement you know and then what I
come to realize is like there it's
easier for me to ask to know women that
I know that have not been if you know
something that's happened to them
because I haven't met that many of you
go hey have you ever been you know had
sexual misconduct in your life or
anything like that and it's so amazing
to me how many women I know that that is
a thing yeah you know and so like I love
that you said that though cuz I feel
like we've had so many conversations
over the years and some of them got very
heated even like with love like what we
would walk way about each other but but
you know talking about things and you
know coming from a male perspective
coming from it's hard you know it's hard
because there isn't really there's not
that much things that are equivalent you
know for men that's my main kind of have
a loof attitude of that like oh what is
that so what do you guys think of like
because this is not this is something
that's been going on for so long you
guys were always talking about it and so
do you think that the me to movement has
made a difference just making people yes
like you like hey this is what's going
on I got a hundred percent I think it's
made a huge difference and I just want
to say though to give you a compliment
back I always appreciated you being very
be honest I mean you know incredibly
offensive back down and be like no you
know I hear you're coming from in
rollers eyes and leaves that would be
like what do you mean I'm gonna really
you did you attempted to defend a lot of
ideas that I think what you're saying is
we hopefully made you a little more
thoughtful about yeah but there were you
know I appreciated your honesty and they
in ours your reaction to our situations
but also just like how you felt about it
from as from a man's perspective and it
started conversations yes he really did
but I think that's what's most important
I feel like that's what's lacking is
everything's black and white whereas
like no you gotta really discuss these
things like consent is like such a it's
not it's not like this or that can you
know it's so it's so like you know
there's so layer and I think it's
getting you know with certain things we
can cite of I mean the last one honestly
I would cite is the Aziz Ansari kind of
article that came out of just like that
kind of area that just got so muddled
for people I think it's it's just it is
interesting I agree with you of just
like where it's going in the sphere of
that gray area I mean I don't think it's
gray but like do you know what I mean
like it's just interesting that it's
being examined in the media I remember
like just you and your stories like how
you guys would talk about certain things
and I'd be like alright well you know
it's like you know you know you'd be
it's something even if it seems so small
and subtle but to you you know if
somebody's brushing up against you or
something like that you're like hey this
is like what are you doing you know and
so it's like you do you feel like that
stuff's like going away or people more
aware of it or do you feel more
empowered to be like hey stop it
yeah I feel more empowered to but I I
feel like I've always done like I've
been on a movie set before where
something happened that was very
inappropriate to one of the actresses
and I straight-up was like this is
unacceptable we're not doing this right
this is not a conversation that we're
going to have on this set like I feel
like I've always been vocal about it but
I feel like yes it is I feel like people
are a little bit scared right now to do
certain things and I do them writings
and yeah
better to be on the scared side of
things like I'm like let's cautious more
cautious I'm wondering how much you're
having to call out stuff versus like
what is even being prevented from
people's fears exact I'm sure like
there's III had recently work on a set
where I had to breastfeed like breast
pump for the first time and it was
amazing like the the ad who was a man
literally was like I want to ask you if
it's appropriate for me to call it
pumping absolutely pumping there's no
other really way to describe it is there
like 10 1/10 2/10 pumping what would be
the technical term if it's not like what
would be the PC term for that if it's
not that milk extraction we got an
extract milk extraction on set we're get
you hit juicing just getting a preferred
Ted juice you do you always have even
before you were a mother Haim said give
me that picture call that so you're not
smoking anymore your womb shriveling you
know he's to say that because I wanted
her to stop smoking you know what my
OBGYN said to me she's like every time
you take a puff of a cigarette when I
was still smoking with it she's like I
want you to think another amazing though
like that desire I was saying to Andy
the other day I'm like I don't even I
walk by it I'm one of those people now
like I don't do that yeah but it doesn't
smell good
yes like it's so amazing like a baby a
baby will take away a lot of bad habits
and that this is my favorite thing that
I said is like you know she comes over
the only time she's nice to me she's
like
yeah you want to go outside with me
while I have a smoke I know we've going
even though you tried it with me like
twice yeah yeah I have probably had a
couple stressful days and like you know
that's how I smoke
yeah it was very fast and you never
finished it it's funny that I did that
whole show and did not smoke weed during
that and then I smoked weed for the
first time after Michael about how she
talks about it you're always like okay
it's gonna be weed day Wednesday I guess
yeah you have like a whip when you first
told me about it oh yeah well first
total you were like this is what I do
now I don't think I'm a pothead but
every once in a while do it I really
don't do it as often as as when I first
tried it I felt like when I started I
was like whoa this is the new glass of
wine guy but it's like back weed
that's like sex no like my me remember
you were a virgin and you thought like
I'm never gonna I'm gonna not gonna be
like that then you have sights on you're
like I gotta have it all the time at
first this is my me to moment I want to
do a song for you do I want to compete
yeah you gonna do it right now oh my god
I don't have all the lyrics just work on
[Laughter]
[Music]
ribbon with Griffin that sounds
different and with Griffin
you had to get that in there well that
guy did a better job she didn't know but
we don't sell yourself short
yeah that's pretty good these kids make
good songs for me all the time and they
take my voice and they put it in these
like hip-hop beats and stuff so don't be
surprised that's probably gonna make it
hey what it does I'll send it to you
guys no I won't get it people now are so
famous you know so funny I was watching
you the yesterday that a Christmas movie
was on when you're the bad guy there's
just a great villain hey cuz I got a lot
of just everything that comes out of
your mouth what what do you know I was
gonna say well she she has to tell you
about her Sundance movie that's coming
up okay well I'm gonna make you boy you
know what it's just one of my favorites
I don't know that you were a straight-up
villain but you were kind of I was kind
of a moment kind of a villain and that
was so much fun to watch it was very fun
to do I play a lot of sweet people so to
get to play villains is your tactic in
office Christmas party and I I'm only
jumping to the Sundance thing because
it's when she's the freezer lead like
she's carrying the whole [ __ ] movie
movies already the one with the one with
the Jack Black I loved that you were the
crazy aunt in that goose I'm very
supportive i watch if that's it if it
says Delia Mel or if it says Mary Bertha
no I'm gonna watch it you're a great
person yes I watch I've seen most of the
things that you've done so that's what I
want to hear about this Sundance cuz I
know that's exciting let me ask you this
okay when you've done something like
you've done a lot of silly things yes a
lot of silly they're just the same thing
for me when I did we're doing
workaholics being Montez it's like you
know then you go out for auditions and
things like by the way I went to this
audition right around workaholics time
like towards the end and if the casting
director says you know you think
hey you know this isn't Montez right yes
Owen so I was I know I've been told that
before
no one's else right someone angry
character right it'd be real weird if I
made it angry when she's like a mom yeah
yeah yeah yeah but so these people that
are doing this to you guys I'm gonna
meet them and so but then when I did I'm
dying up here it was like very it was
great by the way yeah it was challenging
it was very challenging you know this
working with melissa leo she was she was
great but you know and a nightmare at
the same time you know it's so intense
you know but she was like she knew that
she could tell me things so like I'd be
sitting there then all of a sudden she'd
be in my ear you know giving me some
kind of acting advice somehow to be
honest yes very yeah and she put me and
then she got me in her mood she produced
a movie with Whoopi Goldberg and a
Paquin and I was in that movie yeah so
she's great but I'm saying to go from
workaholics to that right it was like he
was like wow what a world opening think
so I'm here what I'm feeling like is
this movie is the same kind of
experience for you so tell us about it
it was the most challenging thing I've
ever done in my life it was so intense
it's called Britney runs a marathon
Britney runs America yeah and I play
Britney and I was in every scene and it
was if I wasn't crying I was running
like it was emotionally and physically
challenging and it was like I was like
everyday like literally I'm sure she
cries and the movie is about like a
woman who wants to change her life and
she decides to run a marathon and it
deals with a lot of body issues and I
lost 40 pounds for the role like just to
experience what the character
experienced and it was it was so
unbelievably life-changing and doing
like a drama it was a dramedy it was it
had some comedy and it was mostly a
drama and so we're in Sundance and we're
in the we're competing in the drama oh
good for you
I know it's gonna be wait you know what
it's gonna be the breakout star what was
the movie that you did the first movie
you were in off of that 22 Jump Street
yes you were now you're gonna be the
breakout dramatic actress of the this
one has a pilot that is going to Sunday
Oh tell us about that actually this is
what the whole thing was really about
because you're the worst
no it's so sad and hilarious I told
Julian is that I have been in like bait
new baby black out what's going on in
the world is delicious
it's insane she's pretty great Monroe is
fantastic I'll bring food that's the
thing right the people do you can still
bring us food I will I will not say no
to food tell us about the pilot so you
have said no to food you look great four
months old what I'm the baby Mads go
breastfeeding y'all breastfeeding looks
like I gotta try giving you a diet no so
this is how bad it is though like I've
just been in such baby mode I had no
idea Sundance even had an episodic
category I did not know this might be
new I think it's like two or three years
old okay and then I didn't know that
this project was even being submitted I
that's a great call it's a great call
and then I get a text from the girl who
created it Daniella lyric is a very good
friend of mine she's on my basketball
team you know Danielle
she loved her but we gotta talk alot bad
I think they fired me we
passive-aggressively never called you
again why are you he was our coach and
he with I was too aggressive the girls
he wasn't he wasn't hashtag me chewing
at all it was more he was just really
aggressively like I was intensive
practice appreciated I know I was like
this is what a coach is but my coach
girls that are like we don't want to
coach what this is for fun I wish I wish
in life we could just cut to him being
like right now in this moment being like
what are you talking then cut to like
just like him screaming at a woman I
wish we had footage that you could cut
it into this yeah yeah oh my god because
you were kind of hilarious yeah but you
guys were hilarious - how about the girl
that was like that was her name she was
like this Jake hit me in the tit and she
stormed off the court in the middle of
the game and we have players who are 25
years old and men 47 I mean it's like an
awesome demographic of women like they
were great I enjoyed unfortunately yes
there are some you know older players
that are like I don't want to be hit in
the tit or the face I have to take care
of my child and it hurts and this isn't
worth it to me and then there's like 25
year-olds like this is worth it yeah
good mix perspectives but anyway but the
creator of the pilot that's going is
called bootstrapped it was created by
Danielle Alaric she's an amazing writer
amazing great creator and we did it
through this production company called
gumption and it was a very low-budget
project that we shot in January right
when I found out I was pregnant I was
like five weeks pregnant at the time and
then the only thing about the only thing
about Sundance though and I'm so glad
you both are in it is like now you guys
have just been a lot of money
now we have to spend a lot of money yeah
that's the thing about Sundance they
don't oh yeah it's not anything we pay
I'm bringing my family out just for me
if you guys I'm trying to tell you now
you should rent a place you know what is
expense movie I did a Sundance movie
like three years ago like the clothes
getting close I'm trying to buy some fun
stuff no yeah no it was like sweater
yeah it was like the combinations were
expensive and like it was all this thing
but it was great and then all the swag
is great let me tell you something your
public if you haven't yet publicist I'm
sure you have a baby the movie you
should hit them up just to be like hey I
know we're not officially working but
can you help me out because it's so much
swag in Sundance you're just gonna go
into a room they're gonna walk you
around so much swag like that [ __ ] no
I'm talking about jackets and boots and
watches in person all kinds of like the
female products are often wazoo is like
makeup and jewelry and like you know I
don't like free tampons and pads god I'd
love a new tampon just one and we want
to thank Tim packs yes so but anyways
you're going for that are you guys gonna
be there the same time we are I movie is
premiering on Monday - you might show is
premiering on Tuesday no I'm doing press
on Monday is the only thing but I don't
know how much that's gonna entail and I
don't know what what time is your
premiere do you know the time I feel
like that like noon yeah I'm hoping I
can figure that out and be prepared for
things like in the middle of the day on
Tuesday - so I don't know if I can see
your what's it called it's called
bootstrap bootstrap yes and it's about
two gals who live in Kansas City that
start a there they started tech company
of an app called [ __ ] that would look
better on me calm it's a comedy it's a
half hour comedy and they're trying to
I know my friend wrote this it's like
it's such a brilliant I have not been
made every woman's pain is actually
working on this now we take a picture of
your sweater yeah it'll tell me where
you bought it how much it was if it says
oh they got that yeah well she wrote it
before that all happened but it's still
a very fun I was like I'm so sweaty
right now you guys are good for both of
you guys you guys came on just even to
to put that stuff out there that's great
I mean I I I just look back at the time
like when we like that workaholics just
going back to it and being like the
birth child of like these careers that
we've had right yeah just to look at it
it's just great you know the breakout
star you would find the negative pours
and any other times just the summer up
just one summer boy yeah well when it
hits this number you're the boy should I
show you the breakout stars the winter
articles movies really about the summer
camp of movies that's gonna be that's
that's on your Wikipedia girls so is
there anything else you guys got going
on besides you got the movie is it what
else is going on really dark no there's
no anything I'm in therapy
I wrote a movies because of the main
host emotionally let's go how is Andy
Andy is great
we are very lovely he's such a good dad
I always knew he'd be a great dad he's
just so in love with her and we're gonna
have a kid that like I mean because of
our schedules and we are so freelance
like she is gonna have she it's equal
dad time and equal mom time and
I'm just really I don't worry but up
forever I just you had a lovely lovely
wedding oh my god Mary Beth was killing
effort wedding killing like 20 minutes
it was like I was like down the aisle
was one of the sweetest things I've ever
seen it's usually at weddings you see
people in there like like very scared a
very nervous and you were just like what
she was walking down she was like hi oh
god you look great like two people who
were there I was like she was it was
like a Soul Train line oh my God look at
all these I remember it like crystal
clear I just like here to celebrate yeah
us and and you know Andy I'm so in love
with him and we're just meant to be and
so did like have all these people just
be like we love you guys we're here in
your honor
no I didn't want it to be fuel stuff I
wanted you guys to feel my excitement it
was perfect we organized this I mean my
father-in-law called me Mary Ann that
was fantastic it was clearly unscripted
it is so there was also a my right and
there was like there was a mic between
you guys and I feel like you you didn't
know that the mic was picking you up but
you're like I just want to kiss you it
was my if you look I don't know if you
remember but like all my nieces and
nephews were in that wedding too and I
look back at the pictures and the video
and they're like they're the ones that
were like oh they're terrified like I've
got a job today and I can't so yeah that
was great I'm saying my best work was
that speech chip man here we go you see
how they just flips everything
this is classic Mary Beth right here I
would honestly just go to brunch with
these two and then just be like this
[Laughter]
but I still had that picture where I
crashed a wedding photos that was my
favorite thing yeah oh my god baby yeah
cuz they were they were you know how you
do the castle when the cocktail hour
isn't right yeah maybe you went in and
just jumped in a bunch of our picture
you living breathing mania my favorite
windows I was looking at my phone like
I'm looking I was it was funny for two
shots and it was like legit out of that
I want them please send help do you know
what a great yeah that was a great time
I love that oh yeah that's why I was
remember the setting it's like it's like
when it's a picture in my head you know
to be having a tour our weddings all
about it was like one man it was just
like did you want or and you're like
he's like come in child I mean you're
like what I haven't thought like when
you get married that you will have a
haunted house that people can go through
or when I get married I love the guy the
person like giving the ceremony it's
gonna be me would be like do you take
this old bat no chubby you have a too
funny watch date with Dateline with this
old bat for the res their life nobody's
date was she's married no dating going
on for you Jesus you always got a fun
bow in your life not for this I know
No oh you got ya for later okay it's
good interesting all right we won't we
won't touch that subject then I really
am glad how what time we get man what
huh
okay cool I just want to make sure we're
what time we act this is how out of it I
am please forgive me but on you were
speaking of I'm dying up here in the
past oh we got canceled it is like
almost six seven months ago
I'm sorry I had no idea it was so great
on that you were my friend Dave creator
yeah didn't create that show but he
created being and he was a writer on
dying up here and so I know I'm a big
family - weird - really dramatic shows
though I don't know you know attached to
Jim Carrey in care that's what I thought
was I think that's what the weird okay
well he's one of my best friends so if
you mean I speak ill of him yeah we're
best best friend Carrie we just hang out
we go to brunches we used to go to
brunch oh good now that would be a weird
and awesome wait what the weirdest part
is that I if I met the brothers yes we
wouldn't be at the brunch I wouldn't be
so that's what it was like you just saw
them at the brunch still you and I
walked over hey what is your dream Oh
can I ask what's your dream brunch -
three people dream brunch three people
Michael Jackson would be there okay it
was a huge I guess we're doing Dead or
Alive
okay she wants to bring up some
hypothetical like you know you might as
well be dead Jim Carrey and Tom Cruise
I'm not gonna be at brunch together all
right you go first
that weird damn cruise and Jim Carrey
could be at a brunch together yeah is
that so that I'll do it here we go
Nicolas Cage Tim Curry Diane Keaton you
need to tell me that wait Benicio del
Toro is not gonna be at your brunch I
mean look I want him to come to
I love that about you
like you yeah you know I told her one
time I said okay [ __ ] marry kill
I said no really rough Blake killed your
dog there's no world where I killed my
dog yeah okay then he's gonna kill these
human Blake's gotta go kill Blake corner
I'm so excited to marry my dog you know
what's funny I also remember going like
on college gigs you know just to get off
this I went to college gigs and I last
30 minutes so the gig I would always be
like anybody have any questions you know
and it would just be it's Blake here
real you know the same person asking
there was a time I sent you a video with
the whole crowd was like we want
yes it was very scary I don't think I
got a lot of that I got a lot of college
boys ah yes I remember a very young boy
like I was like okay I need like read
comments I never where is this story
going I was Witter and here we go
literally a 14-year old boy was like I
want to put things in Alice's this boy's
mother I literally hit that pot I was
like this is weird like it's really
uncomfortable and so I just stopped
reading yeah eventually you've got to
stop
yeah you know wait like like because
it's like when you look at like if you
looked up like you know Marybeth Monroe
naked it's gonna be like your head on
some porn star what's so amazing though
I'm just like and this part is this yeah
I was - I was like this is a sweet ass
but I'm also gleefully taking it from
behind to see you though you and your
sister just examining it you know you
and my sister you guys are great
together we are reversers would be very
great gardens with the cat with a kennel
your way to fashion E to be a great
garden situation very fashionable well
but in a very insane way stacks of
Records you could almost make out their
outfits and they were sensational no
you're right you're right I just so be I
think you'll I think you'll have your
own version of Grey Gardens that I think
will be as insane but maybe not as dirty
yeah I hope it's not as dry I don't want
as many dead animals although I probably
will keep all hell three passes oh no
you're gonna get him stuff Briana and I
talked about oh here we go
getting him stuffed and putting tap
shoes on his feet
deceit this is what we're submitted and
then below it a
old wooden box and put him outside and
so when it's windy you just hear tap oh
oh like a wind chime like a doggie wind
chime like that I'm like great garden
this could happen did that idea look we
have conversations we ran on it we've
been able to know each other for 34
years easily oh and do like basically a
wind chime sure yeah we do tell us you
thought about honestly if you hear this
I'll go
better get my coat I can just see you
guys sitting in the living room he's
shuffling off to Buffalo 100% shuffling
of Buffalo like you're just totally
naming like tapping pattern oh my god
that's actually a really good idea right
what would you it's fun spank spank is
still me kickin I always wanted a bit
halt spank its new dog - huh I do oh my
gosh she is 16 years old just holding on
for dear life she honestly is and I'm
not exaggerating this big she is a
squirrel that can bar with no tail like
just oh yeah having a tough time I'm
wondering it is hard because you know I
talked to my vet and I'm just like I
won't be able to do it like how do you
look at your animal and go well time to
go like you're so in love and you see
them as puppies like I see her yeah as a
puppy and so I they they're awesome they
do give you a list of like do you have
the vet come your house you have to do
that and I'm gonna have the vet come to
my house for sure I make really good
music yeah yeah she's gonna ceremony
type things oh you want to say goodbye -
yeah I mean honestly it's a worm you
know she's been on like a I mean
literally this dog has had so many
health problems like she's been on a
diet for the past five years of like
really horrible food and she's medicine
three times a day I mean and you're
smoking
I mean she has to take my smoke you are
an actual monster right I'm definitely a
monster only to be superseded by my baby
one day it would be the real monster
she'll be the breakout good luck baby
yeah so it's hard I just want to make
sure I am NOT keeping her around for
selfish reasons three times a day she
wants to go outside she can't go on
walks anymore because she's blind but
she wants to go outside she wants to
cuddle you know I just remember my
great-aunt had a German Shepherd that
and they get that polio thing where so
it's dragging itself are you telling me
you don't offer dear life and then no
teeth the teeth and so then it's so like
the dog would bite it was just it was
you know they've gone so I bite you but
you didn't feel it because there was no
tongue that's a weird sensation yeah
like it died while I was visiting you
know and it was just like come on I'm a
dog killer now I could see you being
like I think you have a real sweet part
of you that wouldn't want that dog to
suffer honestly not that you don't go
around killing dogs I'm gonna have to
rescue Vallejo I know I'm gonna have to
I do when you stop calling Vallejo Cujo
know I would know know what it was I
would get all V names you know so I'd be
like like Howl's uh you know house
Valyria more house
Muriel has venereal disease Elsa Anna be
like he's good how's Ubu GOI man well
you know Vallejo is Andy's favorite dog
like if Andy could have a dog in his
life it would be Vallejo he talks about
that dog to this day like the next dog
we get is going to have to be like a Oh
honestly we got this new dog and I was
like she's I love her so much but I'm
like what did we do Vallejo was perfect
and this dog is like eating everything
really and she is so much more she's so
much bigger than a girl only nine months
oh so she's she is a Great Dane mix she
yeah I love great things that's just
surprised that she this is now only
getting another dog like I always
thought that she'd have a kennel of like
you know five or six dogs and cats she's
not here I think she's been so big I
think she's been so busy yeah that's I
just how do you get a dog you're never
here yeah another responsibility like we
had conversations of you feeling guilty
about the whole like why would she
double down I really I will tell you
this I took him to the park that I found
him because I found him it like an
adoption oh you wanna come check it out
check out all these dogs and I what I
took him to that park it was nighttime
thank God there was no one around and I
started crying walking him and I was
like this is where I found you and I go
I go I go my my life is for the better
oh no the better because of you and he's
just like he's a nightmare outside and
seriously like a therapy dog inside
right yes he just like Huddle's with you
so he's trying to escape at all times
this needs to be what you're saying I
I think that's gonna make it into a song
like I am going to take out anybody that
would do they feel this I told to
trainers that and they said no he is
scared you can't protect him and I was
like I feel it and then I cried about
that I cry with Sumi like when somebody
knocks on the door or anything like that
your dog doesn't like oh that's what my
dog does okay yeah and the door oh but
he's like I'm out well we do certain
things and then he knows the person's
okay I'll just say what those things are
for all the burglars watching this
prayer and she lives at gonna come up on
the screen with a map honestly what if
it was just like you just got to watch
one episode of homeland with him and
then he's by the way I would not be
surprised we would be like I like a
rerun of Three's Company or something
like that you know that's funny sure are
you dating that was really good I was
single you're single God you're single
from the lady riesen I'm not really
gonna talk about it cuz it was like it's
so fresh are you on an app is that fresh
yeah I got back on an app are you what
everyone
um I don't even remember I got I got on
rye again III when I see you I swipe I
get out of that fast I don't wanna like
my little sister I know I know I've
never been on a dating app
congratulations
yeah I've been married for
[Laughter]
monster on a now like like if you see
Gillian and you swipe left is like like
hurt Gillian score it says like this
person swipe to left on you know like
you don't know if they like they swipe
unless you know who did them okay and
then Nate and then it doesn't say you've
connected and then like months later you
still haven't connected it's like oh
that person yes yeah yes why would you
ever hurt anybody I feel like I mean no
biggie it is like a feel it is a feeling
of like nobody likes you it's the
feeling of that like if you're like if
you're swiping like ten and then you
don't get any matches on the toilet on
the toilette looking for pound on the
toilet look rhythm with Griffin
ah wipe wipe swipe swipe wipe wipe
swipes tell you that is how I imagine
you on your hand like where am I when
I'm on my hat I feel like it's very rare
and it's late it is rare I would guess
it would be very no because she's
because she's very like she has to have
a dossier you know you very much she's
very much like let me read every single
lines profile well I do I do
well that scenario is not real don't say
like you have to be doing it on the
toilet there's no other place to do it
now do I wipe my phone off when I'm
finished I don't know god I hope so I
hope so the same thing as me which is
I'll get on and I'll be like okay or
like no and then there'll be one person
that I'll be like well they seem great
but I don't know yet and so I'll just
get off
yeah oh my god that's hilarious like I
do anything like in like outside on your
like back porch with Vallejo yeah like
in my little wooden chair yeah my little
rocking chairs tulip lemonade and just
just and Brianna goes who's for supper
tonight and I go I haven't picked here
and then here Vallejo below and I go
Lord it's windy you gonna match just
like that what do you think would happen
if the two of us if we got married I
feel like we'd have so many fights like
we love each other so much but yeah just
get into it
have you ever want to fight anymore
oh you're chill I feel like this breakup
was tough I can just tell is it friend
like you no no no what ever happened
how long were together almost two years
Oh cuz you're you've always been mr.
non-committal I'm glad you went for it
honestly because yeah I will so you know
what I had like two years is a long time
yes in my opinion I mean it is what it
is
you know what I mean you just like I
think you just get to a point where you
know you've we've all been in
relationships you you you were married
before you know I mean so you get to a
point where you go is this forever right
you know and if it's not then the list
of things why it's not they become so
present you know it's like I always
think of it like if it's like a darkroom
let's say it's a darkroom right even the
smallest light is gonna fill you know
it's good you're just gonna be like oh
look at that
I you can't stop looking at yeah
elections with Eric
whoever this is so I think that's what
happens in relationships you know you
ignore all the things that first you
think everything's fine but then when
you start to take a step forward you
tried to like oh I want to see if this
is rest of my life or this is long-term
whatever that even means then you start
to go oh well this is a red flag and
that's a red flag and this is right and
some of them are like oh that's fine but
then 18 my mom calls them unacceptable
six my mom says there are acceptable and
unacceptable negatives you know so I
guess acceptable negative would be like
snoring yeah you know but like drugs
would be an unacceptable negative or
like what about a heart what about
hardcore farting I mean at a poor took
us out at a certain point that might be
a thing for you like you might have like
ignored it at first but every time he's
trying to Dutch oven you in the towards
the end of the two years you're like I
am so sick of your farting you know I'll
just throw this out there though having
been in a relationship for a while with
AMD and now having a child how long you
guys been together - by the way you've
been like 10 years but uh but I will say
that some acceptable negatives in the
camp that you're driving became it can
become unacceptable when a dynamic
changes yes yes yes we're really working
through some things where it's like the
things that I could handle right right
childless oh are now affecting having a
child and me not having the time to be
able to kind of pick up the slack of
those things these are dumb things that
ultimately that's the evolution of a
relationship sorry so can you you know I
you know not to I have no idea who this
woman was that you were in relationship
with and you might have made the best
decision but I do think that sometimes
it's really you shouldn't pigeonhole
yourself into unacceptable negatives
because sometimes you know or acceptable
negatives because they can all change as
people change because I think people
change within relationships you've all
it's so cliche and we evolve in whatever
and are all cliches but no but it's like
it what do you say what it's
my therapist my therapist says that
you're crazy and they're crazy has to
the foundational my gonna make my kid
Griffen Griffen Griffen no but I'm gonna
take her last name how about that yeah
what if I just what if I change like we
got married and I was called Griffin
Munro and then we named our son
you know Munro Griffin yeah I was if you
got married and took your wife's name
mm-hmm
I will go near Zieve on whatever the
biggest show is and just be topless I
was so shocked do you think you would
ever do that I don't think it even
matters I don't think that seemed too
big you I think Julian is correct I
could never see you just taking her last
name fully but i but i but to me first
of all I have no connection to I have no
connection to the name Griffin really no
no none at all my girlfriend is like my
mother's laughs he wasn't my father you
know I mean I just like it cuz my name
is Eric Graham Griffin so it spells egg
so I wouldn't want to mess that up
oh my gosh do you remember when we had a
day we had a day where we tried to
figure out what your name was I couldn't
stop laughing and Eric was such a fun
shooting with Aaron gravy Griffith rape
killed me great great destroyed me
that's the only thing I don't think
there's any like who cares about that I
don't really I don't hold on to what if
her last name was Eric Eric Graham barek
okay what if you're okay what if your
husband's last name was like Killian
you know Gillian Gillian Killian no
one's on it no one will come no one will
be on listen ladies we've been I could
tell the weekend gap for a long time and
I don't want to keep you yapping for
much longer but I just want to say I
really want to thank you both for coming
this is what workaholics was for how
many cc's yeah we were the other three
this is the other three with the other
thank you both for coming on it's a year
just again the breakout star like we're
done breaking her out
well this is actually the most fun I've
had on my podcast yeah I love you both
but anyways guys thank you again for
sticking around for another episode of
riffing with Griffin and once again I
want to thank Jillian Bell and the
beautiful and talented what what the
[ __ ] just happened there Wow
okay let's start again I mean you are
but having kids where you have to like
yeah give me the most compliments let's
hear it all right ladies gentlemen I
want to thank you
we're gonna cut to that please gentlemen
think I want to thank the both beautiful
now okay we do it again ladies gentlemen
my friends and my sisters in crime
Jillian and Marybeth thank you for
coming on the show it was just no edge